hello and welcome to aniko today we're
going to explain the anime series called
doraro
as lord daigo waits for his wife nui to
give birth he records the time he made a
pact with the 12 demons in the hall of
hell prepared to tread the path of evil
in exchange for power when his first son
is born the demons extract their payment
the child is born without limbs facial
features or skin the baby is set to
drift in the river and left to its fate
sixteen years later he's now a young man
traveling alone wearing prosthetics made
by dr jukai while hunting a sludge-like
demon he encounters dororo a young petty
thief being beaten by three men who
donaro cheated out of their goods the
demon attacks and devours the men but
the young man destroys it with blades
inside his prosthetic arms following the
death of the demon the man's missing
skin reappears and a demon statue in the
hall of hell is split by lightning
meanwhile back in ishigawa daigo's
second son tahoe maru returns home from
hunting however her mother still misses
her first son
dornano accompanies the young man who
seems to be unable to see hear or talk
however he has excellent sword skills
superhuman strength and the ability to
detect friendly or unfriendly beings by
the colour of their souls doraro takes
the young man to a village run by a
beautiful woman named bandai and offers
to slay a local monster which rings a
pilgrim bell
while there they meet the blind monk
known as biva hoshi who can also detect
people's souls they discover bandai is
actually a demon who's been eating
travellers and after a long and intense
fight the young man slays the demon the
monster reappears ringing its bell and a
villager explains it's the spirit of the
first being the villagers killed the
young man reveals his name hyakimaru to
dororo and the monk as bandai statue in
the hall of hell gets struck by
lightning yakima regains his central
nervous system thus regaining the
ability to feel pain
meanwhile daigo is told the sakai clan
appears to be preparing for war
many years ago jukai sensei a doctor
found lord daigo's abandoned and
deformed infant on a riverbank he took
the child home and made special
prosthetics for him so he could move
about and appear normal six years later
the doctor gave him the name hyakimaru
after the kid killed eliza demon and his
right leg was magically returned to him
jukai realized that although the boy
attracted demons his body parts had
probably been stolen by demons the
doctor inserted swords into hyakimaru's
prosthetic arms before the young man
left to travel the land alone
dora wrote chats with the girl while
hyakimaru stands outside experiencing
the feeling of rain for the first time
suddenly yakima detects a demon sword
and rushes off he encounters a man
wielding the sword and only manages to
defeat him by trapping the sword in his
prosthetic leg doraro goes to retrieve
the leg but is pulled back to its owner
when he touches the sword the girl finds
her brother danosuke and takes him home
but he's only interested in regaining
the sword meanwhile yakimaru disarms
dorado but tanosuke seizes the sword
again and attacks yakimaru this time
hyakimaru kills him and breaks the sword
which returns his ears to him the next
morning in the sakai territory yakima
encounters mio but he collapses from his
wounds the travelers stay with mio and a
group of orphaned children at an
abandoned temple while mia works at
night serving the sakai troops as a
prostitute meanwhile biba hoshi finds a
better place for them however it's
inhabited by a demon despite his wounds
still healing yakimaru goes to fight it
bibahoshi is concerned yakimaru's white
aura is starting to show hints of demon
red they encounter the antlion
larvae-like demon which bites off the
lower half of hyakimaru's real leg
leaving him screaming in agony viva
hoshi heads back to mio's camp with
hyakimaru his leg is half gone but his
voice has now returned he slowly adjusts
to using his hearing and his voice with
the help of mio they become drawn to
each other and the red in his soul fades
although only partially recovered
yakimaru returns to kill the demon he
succeeds in killing the demon and his
leg heals however when he and dorado
return to the temple they find meow
mortally wounded and diego troops
murdering the orphans because they
believe mio is a sakai spy enraged by
the attack on mio yakimaru goes berserk
slaughtering all the daigo troops until
dororo intervenes fearing hyakimaru may
become a demon himself after burying the
dead kyakimaru and dororo continue their
travel
a dark cloud containing a demon appears
over a village and the villagers
hurriedly prepare a woman as a
sacrificial bride to appease it as
hyakimaru and donoro see the bridal
parade traveling up the mountain saru a
wild boy tries to stop the sacrifice
after the boy tells them the story of
the demon dororo and hyakimaru agreed to
exterminate the demon a dark cloud
envelopes them and the demon appears as
a large centipede however yakima is
unable to differentiate it from the
cloud as they both show red to his
vision and it swallows the woman
dorado and saru devise a plan to create
an explosion using the sulfurous gases
emitted by the mountain which sets the
demon ablaze but has little effect
tororo then jumps on the demon's head
and caused the hyakimaru enabling him to
locate and attack the centipede by sound
destroying it the dark cloud dissipates
and hyakimaru
and the woman who is still alive from
being swallowed whole fall into water
saru is relieved to find his sister and
agrees to move into the village with her
akimaru regains his sense of smell and
for the first time addresses dorado by
name
dorado falls ill with fever and
hyakimaru takes him to a temple for
treatment later doraro recovers but the
priestess reveals that hiyakimaru doraro
is actually female calling tororo young
girl after removing her clothes to wash
them meanwhile daigo is told hyakimaru
may be alive from a survivor of the
attack on mio's camp
a crab-like monster devours a man after
destroying his boat meanwhile the
drought in the daigo lands worsens
whilst the asakura clan gathering on the
border he visits the temple and finds
more demon statues destroyed and the
demons inform him hyakimaru is still
alive and is slowly retrieving the
stolen pieces of his body
daigo's son tahoe maru discovers his
father is searching for a baby
later tahoma and his two bodyguards
mutsu and hyogo encounter a village
where they speak of a monster in the
lake which eats fishermen he leads a
group of villagers in their boats onto
the lake and attacks and damages the
monster but it's too fierce and they're
forced to retreat tahoe maru then has
the villagers constructed trap intending
to lure the monster into a shallow
channel where the water can be drained
out the plan works and tahumaru mutsu
and hyogo attack it together however the
monster fights back and almost devours
hyogo but at the last minute hyakimaru
arrives and slays it tahomaru is left
wondering who this stranger is the
homaru learns hyakimaru's name as the
two travelers arrive in the daigo
capital there they see a play depicting
daigo as a great slayer of demons
protected by the goddess of mercy viva
hoshi seeks the truth at the horn of
hell while hiyakimaru and tororo visit
the remnants of fort banmon it was built
by daigo and is supposedly cursed by a
demon they find remnants of a timber
wall where the asakura pin bodies of
their enemies with arrows they encounter
a young boy sukeroku who wishes to cross
to the asakura side and rejoin his
family meanwhile dahomaru's bodyguards
report the incident with hyakimaru to
daigo who realizes his son is alive and
decides to kill him and maintain the
prosperity of his domain ignoring his
wife's pleas
tahoe maru overhears their exchange and
later comes across a demented woman who
was present at hyakimaru's birth she
tells him how the demons ate everything
but left the boy alive knight falls at
banmon and a nine-tailed fox demon
appears when it attacks yakimaru
tsukeroku uses the distraction to pass
the wall with doraro in pursuit however
they're captured by asakura centuries
the demon is eventually chased off by
arrows of a squadron led by daigo
himself who then approaches hyakimaru
hyakimaru doesn't recognize his father
and is confused when he sees demonic red
in daigo's soul daigo orders his archers
to fire at hiakimaru who flees meanwhile
doraro and sukiroku are held in an
asakura prison with other prisoners but
dorado manages to escape in the daigo
compound tahumaru confronts his mother
about his brother's fate but his father
explains the bargain he made with the
demons to save their land yakimaru
appears in his scene by his mother and
brother but daigo orders him killed
dahomaru is horrified but daigo asks
stahomaru if he would be willing to
sacrifice the land to save his brother
the asakuras start to kill their
prisoners at the ban mon to provoke a
war and the daigo army charges forward
attracting the fox demon lord tiger
arrives with his army and tahumaru who
has reluctantly accepted his father's
decision attacks yakimaru hyakimaru
breaks tahumaru sword and damages his
right eye then kills the demon which is
sucked into the banmon louis arrives and
begs forgiveness for her complicity in
diego's bargain she then stabs herself
and her sacrifice causes her goddess of
mercy statue to collapse the banmon
survivors of sukiroku's village arrive
and sukiroku is reunited with his mother
viva hoshi picks up nui's small headless
wooden statue of the goddess of mercy
which sacrificed its own head
hiyakimaru's birth so the child wouldn't
lose his head in his father's bargain
with the demons and his gentle green
aura fades
later hyakimaru and doloro visit an
onsen where they encounter viva hoshi
and other children who see a map which
appears on doraro's back nui is shown to
have survived but dahomaru has been
blinded in his right eye
in a flashback doraro's father the
bandit hibu guru drew part of a map of
the location to his hidden money onto
the back of his wife and the rest on
doraro's back so they could retrieve it
together later dororo memorised the map
on her mother's back before she died in
the present bibahoshi and hiyakimaru
realized the map appears when doraro's
back heats up which biva hoshi says
gives her some choices in life
yakimaru continues his search for demons
unconcerned even when a huge baby-like
monster grabs doraro they arrive at a
burnt out temple and the monsters
disappear as they encounter sabame the
lord of the land carrying a flower
offering to the spirit who inhabits the
site he invites them to stay at his home
where he says the temple housed the
nunnery which exploited children before
it was struck by lightning and destroyed
killing everybody inside that night the
travelers are attacked by a
caterpillar-like monster but when
hyakimaru wounds it a huge moth-like
demon mai mai omba appears and carries
it away the mouth lands near sabah may
and transforms into a white-haired woman
after she tells saba mei the food he
provided for her children was too strong
he consoles her and promises to protect
her and her children dorado visits
sabahme's prosperous village where
everyone seems happy she finds a rice
storehouse deep in the forest but is
pushed into the basement by the
villagers it's filled with the
caterpillar monsters which menace dorado
but the baby monster returns to save her
the monster burst open releasing the
spirits of the children from the temple
which sabah may and the villagers had
fed to my my ombre after burning it down
outside the village sabah may tells
hyakimaru how he accepted the maimai
omba who fed on samurai and beast to
protect the village and then took her as
his wife the maimai ombu moths emerged
from their crystallines and attack
yakimaru who fiercely fights back
however the last one destroys
hyakimaru's prosthetic leg and then
sacrifices itself to set fire to the
village meanwhile doraro burns down the
storehouse destroying the caterpillars
in the village's rice supplies causing
the villagers to fight amongst
themselves over the remaining food
hyakimaru finds and kills the original
mai mayumba which returns his spinal
column to him he and doraro walk back
through sabahme's burnt out village
where many villagers lie dead including
sabah may donald wonders if they did the
right thing but hyakimaru states his
only concern is killing demons doraro
and hyakimaru walk their separate ways
but a bandit named itachi who betrayed
doraro's father finds her itachi has
half of the mat from doraro's mother's
back and demands to see dora rose half
she denies knowledge of a map but
hitachi and his men take her with them
believing she's memorized it they travel
for days following donald's mother's
half of the map which itachi discovered
after he dug up her body they arrive at
cape hakotsu where the treasure is
located but can't reach it without a
boat after failing to find boats at a
nearby village which they believe was
destroyed by bandits they meet shiranui
a one-armed youth who offers to take
them across they board two boats pulled
by huge sharks jiro maru and saburo
midway across shiranui reveals he fed
his arm to the sharks however they
developed a taste for human flesh so he
then killed the villagers to feed them
on a signal the sharks capsize one of
the boats and devour the men on board
not wanting them to gorge themselves he
leaves saburo maru to watch the second
boat until they come back later to eat
disheartened itachi recounts how he and
his men were exploited by his lord
donald berates them for giving up and
jumps in the water as to you
on a signal they pull her up and when
the shark surfaces they stab and kill it
they then paddle ashore at cape hakotsu
when shiranui comes ashore to
investigate he's savagely beaten by the
bandits itachi strips donaro's clothes
looking for the map and realizes doraro
is a girl while the heat of the fire
reveals the map on her back with the
completed map they tie up dororo and
leave while shiranui vows revenge
elsewhere as yakima struggles to walk he
passes a monk who tells him of a man
nearby who can give him a new leg
jukai is adding limbs to the dead on a
battlefield when a ghoul attacks but
hyakimaru appears and kills him back in
his cage jukai is horrified when
hiyakimaru explains what his father did
to him suddenly a landslide blocks the
entrance to the cave while hiyakimaru
digs his way out he reveals he's not
alone as he remembers doraro emerging
from the cave they find the fruit of a
nearby demon tree producing more ghouls
hyakimaru slays the moon until he
eventually pierces the tree's heart and
destroys it at the daigo compound nui
recovers but tahoma leaves to kill a
reported ghoul without visiting her he
and his aides find and wound a rat like
ghoul taho maru then burns the building
to kill both the ghoul and its offspring
who are still alive inside pledging his
sword to defend daigo land when they
return daigo sends tahoe maru and a
small army to kill hiakimaru
hyakimaru rose a small boat towards cape
hakotsu
shiranui calls on the giant shark jiro
maru to eat saburo maru's body and it
evolves into a demon capable of moving
onto land it attacks doraro but she's
saved by hyakimaru who slays the demon
hyakimaru's left leg is restored
meanwhile itachi finds a cave and two of
his men rush in but are killed by
booby-trapped explosives tahoe maru and
a fleet land on the shore in pursuit of
yakimaru and tahumaru gives orders to
leave no one alive several of hitachi's
remaining men fall to daigo arrows and
doraro and hiakimaru come across a
wounded itachi hyakimaru is attacked by
tahumaru mutsu and hyogo so itachi grabs
donaro and flees high above shinanui
detonates the booby trap bombs he
removed in an attempt to kill everyone
killing himself and causing a landslide
many of tahoma's men are killed and
hyogo is badly wounded so they decide to
withdraw assuming hyakimaru is dead
meanwhile doraro and the mortally
wounded hitachi fall into a cave created
by the explosion and discover the
treasure itachi dies after seeing it
hyakimaru finds donoro who decides to
leave the treasure hidden until she
decides what to do with it hiyaki maru
and donoro seek the swordsmith to repair
the swords in kyakimaru's prosthetic
hyakimaru refits the repaired sword and
continues his journey with doroth tahoma
and his aides observed misfortune before
ling daigo's villages and since it
started at the borders and is spreading
inwards they suspect the demons are
upset hyakimaru isn't dead back in his
compound daigo realizes his deal with
the demons has been revoked since the
destruction of the goddess of mercy
statue and the days of prosperity are
now over meanwhile hiyaki maru and
dorado encounter dai spot saburota who's
hunting a local demon that ate his
mother they're laying weight in a
gigantic nue appears hyakimaru goes to
fight it but is intercepted by saburota
who now delights in seeing the demon
devour terrified travelers during the
fight hyakimaru and dorado fall down a
rocky embankment and dorado's arms
become trapped hyakimaru is unable to
free her despite breaking his left
prosthetic arm and subterranean water
begins to rise suddenly viva hoshi
appears and frees donato though his
sword is broken again determined to
regain his body hyakimaru attacks and
badly wounds the nue it eats saburota in
desperation absorbing him into his body
hyakimaru finally slays it however no
part of his body is returned to him this
time even when he cuts the new way to
pieces much to the horror of dororo
biva hoshi watches sadly as the
brutality results in hyakimaru's aura
gaining a red heart thinking he has a
heavy fate to bear hyakimaru realizes he
must confront daigo to have his body
fully restored hyakimaru approaches
daigo territory and doloro is saddened
his single-minded desire to recover his
body parts they're recognized by a
villager who notifies daigo meanwhile
the situation worsens in daigo territory
villages which have become diseased or
burnt and their inhabitants killed
able-bodied men are conscripted for the
war against the threatening asakura clan
horses including a nursing mother horse
called midoro are requisitioned tahomaru
decides to take mutsu and hyogo to stop
hyakimaru himself
they find hiyakimaru and doraro at a
ravine littered with soldiers bodies and
attack him together yakimaru severs
mutsu's right arm and hyogo's left arm
and again cuts tahoma's right eye as
doraro looks on in horror at hiyaki
maru's savagery
suddenly a group of men sent by daigo to
protect their prince in tv the leader
sends mira loaded with explosives
towards yakimaru killing the horse and
blowing hiakimaru into the ravine doraro
is captured by the villagers and
tahomaru is subdued by a dart when he
refuses to leave later spirits possess
miidoro's body parts turning it into a
flaming horse
tahoe maru's group returned home with
dorado while daigo prepares to repel an
impending attack by the asakura clan
planning to fight her ban mom hyakimaru
is enraged because donaro has been
kidnapped his rage drawing the demon
horse to him dahomaru visits hyogo's
sister mutsu who lost her right arm and
is also weak from a disease she was
hiding but she refuses to see him as she
won't risk infection meanwhile nui frees
doraro in gratitude for providing
companionship for her son hiyakimaru and
leaves with him their boat is smashed in
the strong current and they're rescued
by daigo refugees including biva hoshi
nui continues to stay to help care for
the sick and wounded mutsu leaves the
compound badly ill prompting tahoe maru
and hyogo to go after her elsewhere
hiyaki maru has joined with the demonic
horse midoro and is cutting a bloody
sway through daigo soldiers seeking
doraro mutsu staggers to the demon
temple and offers herself to the 12th
and final demon to protect the land and
its people tahomaru and hyogo arrive to
see her offer rejected however when
tahumaru mutsu and hyogo later intercept
hyakimaru their wounds have been healed
by the demon mutsu and hyogo each bear
one of yakimaru's rear arms and tahomaru
has his two eyes daigo villagers near
the border prepare for the impending war
and midoro's fall runs away yakimaru
attacks the hamadu mutsu and hyogo to
reclaim his eyes and arms meanwhile nui
and doraro arrive at the battle but are
held back by biva hoshi midoro attacks
mutsu and hyogo but is distracted by the
arrival of a fall and is wounded enraged
midoro tears off yogo's head and crushes
mutsu but their bodies are controlled by
the demon which uses their arms to
fatally wound midoro on their deaths
hyakimaru's arms return to him and he
grabs the two sword blades that were in
his prosthetics with his bare hands to
keep fighting tahomaru confused by
emotions when he sees nui and doraro
approach hiakimaru runs off with
tahomaru in pursuit at the border daigo
leads his army forward determined to
feed the asakura and give meaning to his
decisions hyakimaru follows tahomaru to
the diego castle and their fight resumes
during the struggle they knock over a
candle stand setting the castle on fire
the smoke alerts doro and nui who are
drawn by concern for the young brothers
tahoe maru and hiakimaru continue their
fierce battle inside the burning daigo
castle each believing it's their
inherited domain meanwhile louis leaves
birahoshi and doraro while she enters
the castle through a hidden tunnel and
meets yukai above them hyakimaru finally
defeats tahomaru but doesn't kill him
the demon with hyakimaru's eyes tries to
take control of tahomaru but he removes
the eyes which return to hyakimaru after
hikimaru slays the demon he becomes
whole for the first time and jukai gives
him a newly carved goddess of mercy
statue doraro and hyakimaru are reunited
as the castle burns nui tends to
tahomaru as he dies in her arms and the
castle collapses meanwhile the last
demon statue falls in the hall of hell
and daigo leads his army against the
asakura losing many of his men later
dorado proposes to retrieve the treasure
to help the daigo refugees while
hiyakimaru finds his father wounded but
defiant in the hall of hell however when
hiyakimaru departs without killing him
leaving the goddess of mercy statue
behind daigo realizes if he hadn't made
the pact with the demons hiakimaru may
have had the ability to save his land
hyakimaru departs alone leaving doraro
behind knowing however that they will
meet again in the future in the final
scene some years later doraro a young
woman runs to gree hyakimaru who smiles
as he turns to see her that's all folks
don't forget to like and subscribe for
more